no matter where you're from what you
look like what your familiar unit looks
like it doesn't matter you're a hero
you've always been exceptional you've
always been worthy this family is a
family that I know I grew up around a
family like miles
you know being a hero shouldn't look one
way we should all feel empowered to know
that we can go and save the world and so
especially with this go around with so
many spider verses available everyone
can feel like they're a hero that to me
is what's really important and special
this is a pretty hardcore origin story
not only is the soundtrack amazing and
the animation is great and the direction
is unbelievable but at the same time
everyone is a part of this universe I
think that that's all we truly want in
the end is to feel like we belong this
iteration of Spider-Man opens it up even
broader and wider
[Music]